Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan, although you may
know me from across the Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we're continuing on our Komodor tutorial. If
you haven't seen part one, pause this and
go watch it now.
In part one, I show you how to
deploy the Komodor agent to your Kubernetes cluster.
From there, we're able to use the Komodor
UI
to troubleshoot and debug our Kubernetes cluster.
We get really rich context aware user interface
that allows us to browse our workloads and
work out what is wrong based on the
events within the system.
And as we all know, when things go
wrong, the more information at hand you have,
the easier your job is.
So Komodor also ships with a whole bunch
of integrations. We're going to take a look
at a few of them today.
The first one I wanna take a look
at is Sentry.
Sentry is something that if you're an application
developer, you probably already know. It's an open
source tool that you integrate into your application.
They support pretty much every runtime available.
And whenever things go wrong,
it sends an alert with a stack trace
to the Sentry system.
Meaning, you can log in to Sentry, see
the stack traces, how many times have happened,
when the last one happened,
and more information about the request
depending on where it runs. It could be
mobile, desktop,
browser, who knows.
But everything that you need to handle that
exception should be at your fingertips.
So of course, Komodor provide a way to
present that information as part of their UI.
Let's take a look.
So here's the Komodor UI
and our pretty healthy cluster that we've seen
in the first tutorial.
The first thing I want to do is
pop down to integrations
where you'll see that I've already added Sentry
to my Komodor setup.
However, I'm gonna quickly walk you through the
steps involved.
So first, you need to go to Sentry.
Sign up for an account. There is a
free tier. Enjoy.
From there, we go to settings
and then developer settings.
And here, you'll be able to add a
new internal integration.
You click next and fill in
just a few details.
Give it a name. I called mine Komodor.
Not very inventive,
but fit for purpose.
From the Komodor side, when you go to
add the Sentry integration, it will give you
a URL to use as the webhook URL.
So don't make it up. Copy and paste.
Next, you'll need to select project,
read, and issue an event, read.
Lastly,
select tick box, on issue,
and save.
And you're good to go.
From the Komodor side,
scroll down,
click install integration,
and the URL that you need to copy
is here.
If you get confused at any point,
jump to the Komodor documentation.
Select integrations
and Sentry,
and I'll walk you through step by step.
Now that we've done the setup, we need
to cause a little bit of panic,
pun intended,
as you'll see.
First, you need to modify the deployment resource
for your application.
Here, I have a very simple deployment dot
YAML for my application called
Go Crash.
In order to have Komodor connect the dots
with Sentry, you will have to provide the
Sentry DSN as an environment variable.
I'm doing that as a hard coded value.
As you can see, I would strongly encourage
you to store this as a secret
and mount it inappropriately.
You can also set the Sentry environment to
which I set it to production.
So let's deploy this to my cluster with
the Komodor agent installed.
We can run kubectl
apply
example app
deployment.jaml.
From here, we can run kubectl
get pods to watch the rollout status of
our application.
And already, we can see that our application
is in a crash loop back off.
Let's head over to Komodor and see why.
Alright. So here we are in the Komodor
UI,
and we can actually see that currently, Go
Crash appears to be healthy.
But if we click on it, we can
see that this application has failed, had a
brief stunt as maybe healthy, which I think
was just being rescheduled on another node,
and then began to crash again.
So in a moment, this will change to
GoCrash being an unhealthy application.
But we can already see down here
that we have two notifications
from Sentry itself.
Now we'll see the code in a minute
and why Sentry says, hey. It works. But
this is me sending a default capture message
or event to the Sentry system.
And then we also see this is a
test panic.
So if we click on this, we get
some more context.
We can see that a Sentry issue was
created, example three,
with level fatal.
And we can see that this is currently
unresolved.
So if we click view issue on center,
it takes us to here,
where we can see the go run time
for application
is 01:19.5
running on a Linux machine, which is AMD
sixty four.
If you scroll down, we see the message
that this is a test panic,
as well as the packages available
and the Go SDK version.
Now these events are as rich as you
want them to be by your instrumentation and
the Go application.
So let's take a look at that.
If we open main.Go, you'll see my hard
code is sent to DSN, which you really
shouldn't do. Trust me. Do not do that.
And then we'll see
that we have the capture message I sent
as a test to ensure that the central
integration was working,
followed by
a panic.
I'm explicitly telling this application
to crash.
So let's remove that
and replace it with a hello world.
Now I'm not going to go through the
motions of committing, rebuilding the image, pushing this
to cluster, pushing out a new deployment.
Instead, I'm just gonna pop over
and resolve.
Now we can refresh the Komodor page
and we'll see that this is a test
panic has been resolved.
Now this is a contrived situation,
but it's important to know that if you
instrument your application with a tool like Sentri,
integrate it with Komodor,
you can get real time information with that
integration directly in the Komodor UI,
and that is a cool feature.
So it's time to say goodbye to Go
Crash, and we'll move on to the next
integration.
So another tool that developers love to use
well, I love to use, but I'll speak
for all developers now,
is Grafana,
especially in coordination with Prometheus and Alert Manager.
So let's pop down the integration list,
And you'll see at the bottom left,
we have an integration with Prometheus Alert Manager.
If we click on this, we'll get another
URL that we can hook up to our
alert manager
to inform Komodor when things are alerting.
So let's copy this URL like so.
So if you're not familiar with configuring alert
manager, it all happens through a Kubernetes secret.
Here's the one that I pulled out of
my cluster.
This is this generic Kube Prometheus install.
However, to the receivers list, I've added one
more.
So all I need to do to get
this into the alert manager in my cluster
is first secure it.
And by secure, I mean, 64 encode.
So let's cat
my alert manager configuration,
pipe it through base 64,
and copy it in to my buffer.
From here, I can edit the secret in
my monitoring
namespace
called alert manager main.
I can use my VIM shortcuts to say
I want to change to the end of
the line
and drop in our new base 64 encoded
config map
and save.
We can now pull the pods
from the monitor namespace
and delete all the alert manager pods forcing
the configuration to be reloaded.
Like so.
Next, we run a git and we'll see
that our alert managers are coming up quite
nicely.
Now we can go to the alert manager
UI by port forwarding to the service on
port nine zero nine three. And if we
go to status,
scroll all the way down to the bottom,
we'll see our Komodor webhook receiver configured.
So now we're gonna make one more change
to the alert manager config
to tell it to start written some of
our alerts to Komodor.
And we're going to add
matters
receiver
Komodor.
This should send all alerts to Komodor
like so.
So we rotate the alert manager pods one
more time.
So now if we go to status and
scroll down, we'll see
the Komodor root receiver
and our webhook configuration.
That's all it takes to start sending the
alert manager letters to your Komodor instance.
So let's pop back over to Komodor.
Let's just get this reload for good measure.
And it would appear that everything cell looks
green,
which is awesome.
However,
let's pop over to events.
So already, we can see the top issue
is from alert manager.
A cube scheduler has disappeared from the Prometheus
target discovery. This alert is still firing,
and we can see the summary,
severity,
alert name,
and a description and runbook URL.
Now because my Prometheus is not exposed on
the public Internet, I'm going to right click
and copy this address instead of clicking the
link directly.
From here, I can paste it in and
just change the service name to be localhost.
Now we have the Prometheus dashboard and the
query that is triggering the alert.
Now quickly before we finish, I wanna pop
over to Grafana.
Could Prometheus configures Grafana for us as well?
And in fact, if we go to Grafana
alerting, we'll see that we have seven filing,
two pending, and everything else is normal.
Now these are pretty much the same alerts
from our alert month alert manager instance. So
I'm gonna configure Grafana
to speak to Komodor.
We can click on the bell and go
to contact points
where we can create a new one.
I'll call this Komodor.
And this will be a webhook integration.
We can drop the URL
and click save.
Next, we go back to the bell
and see notification policies.
And I'm gonna modify the root policy.
I'm gonna set the default contact point to
be Komodor
and hit save.
Of course, if you're familiar with Grafana, you
can set specific policies based on labels
to match your own requirements.
And it's as easy as that.
Integrating Sentry,
Grafana,
and Prometheus with Alert Manager with Komodor
brings you unprecedented
context when debugging, when things go wrong.
So I hope this guide was useful to
you. There's one more part still to come
where we'll be taking a look at automating
the deploy of Komodor and vCluster.
I'll see you then. Have a great day.